[Applaudissements]
alors il ya maintenant trois ans on
associer moi même architecte avions de
plus en plus de travail et surtout des
projets plus conséquents
les équipements publics et donc
avait plutôt derrière nous les projets
de particuliers qu'on avait pu le
réaliser avec l'aide de guillaume
ingénieur structure qui s'était
reconverti en artiste en bois c'est
peut-être paupérisation qu'on a pu faire
avec lui et est donc il ya trois ans on
a une une demande un petit peu
particulière un couple d'amis vient nous
rencontrer me demande si l'on peut leur
construire une micro maison une times
puisque selon eux c'était la seule
solution pour être propriétaire des
jeunes n'est pas tous les moyens et à
enzo pour des raisons que vous
connaissez
ils étaient délimités et l'encrier terre
donc cette manque d'eau particulière du
times alors mountain house qu'est-ce que
cet égard aux par comprendre que c'est
une minuscule maison faire très bon
niveau d'anglais
je sais pas avec quoi de quoi s'agit
réellement et et je décide quand même de
l'an tirent des roquettes
au caire on va y aller on va se
renseigner et et on les praires la clio
que l'on connaît bien et qui on a déjà
expérimenté des petits modules bois à
des kits extension est et a donc ok pour
le nouveau challenge et votre joueur
êtes un petit peu je rencontrerai que
tania rousset micro maison voile et
transportable mais c'est pas que ça je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi donc nous
vous rendons que l'architecte concepteur
on ne peut pas imaginer qu'on se voit un
espace d'habitation donc une maison un
logement on peut pas imaginer ne pas le
penser comme un comme un projet
architectural à part entière ce qui est
moins à des besoins spécifiques qui soit
une vraie réponse à des besoins des
futurs habitants
et c'est là tout à l'heure a ajouté avec
l' expertise
de guillaume qui avait sa société dans
l'ossature bois pour créer une avance
qui va devenir plus tard ainsi tiny de
laminoirs architecture avec ou sans eau
donc on a associé de compétences pour
définir ce cette nouvelle aventure qui
est une aventure parallèle
et on s'est lancés complètement
d'engouement détail n'gaous donc quand
la découverte du mouvement des
réglementations a passé pas mal de temps
à discuter avec les gens du et qui
vivent à l'otago qui avait l'envié d'y
vivre dans l'état ni à éplucher pas mal
de sites internet de documentation et
stations de ce que c'était réellement
comprendre les hors-jeu de ce mouvement
et ainsi commencer à travailler notre
première tania aux donc que les premiers
premier plan les premières esquisses de
plus en plus sortir parce que l'enjeu
c'est quand même degré une maison
entière une maison traditionnelle toutes
ces pièces dans ces cas là les cas elle
savait pouvant que certaines chambres ou
que certaines années donc l'enjeu
étonnant donc on se faire le maximum
sur une surface minimum et avant de vous
développer le produit et le mouvement et
le mode de vie
un petit rappel historique ces objets
schaeffer vous voyez ici qui construisit
sa tanière hausse aux états unis à la
suite de la crise immobilière et qui
initia en fait un mouvement pour lequel
coco gens d'adhérer des jo qui est en
quête d'un nouvel habitat fico
économique qui est alternée et en
français annonce un jour c'est un
directeur de revue spécialisée en
construction écologique qui importa le
concept est qui qui fit qui fut porte ça
ça tania rousse est en fait il a apporté
le boom en france à graines à germer de
nombreuses personnes sont tombées sont
tombées amoureuses de se nourrir de vie
et était près du poids à découvrir ce
nouveau type d'habitat donc nous aussi
on s'est mis à fond là-dedans on n'a
rien dit des propres tania hausse
on a passé beaucoup de temps en phase de
conception avec les gens que vous voyez
là et n'est qu'à l'oral
boucle qui étaient tentés par avoir la
mention avec nous il a fallu les
connaître c'est une véritable aventure
une aventure humaine parce que celle-ci
lycée pendant leur quotidien connectant
habitude connaître leur consommation
pour adapter au plus au plus près leur
nouvelle maison
est ce que quand même s'agit d'une
raison dans cette toute petite surface
et surtout adapté des besoins
énergétiques puisque cette année est
entièrement tôt
ensuite ça a été une aventure technique
puisqu'il a fallu utiliser l'ensemble
des des critères des normes et des
réglementations à savoir la largeur on
est à deux mètres cinquante cinq au
retour c'est bien paris routier on a une
longueur 15,7 m une hauteur limitée à 4
mètres trente et un tonnage à 3,25
donc à part ce contrat la libération est
totale
et nous sans expérience avec l'ordre
bien faire un petit peu surenchérit dans
dans la volonté d'intégrer beaucoup de
mobilier ce qu'on voulait absolument
d'idc terminent leur maison faut
vraiment qu'on intègre un petit peu tout
dans cette petite surface qu'on va faire
on va essayer d'intégrer beaucoup
mobilier puisqu'angelina leur affaire on
va essayer de faire un truc super g a
des super optimisé et et en avait aussi
mais mais nos architectes n'est pas
habitué à travailler avec limite de
poids nous on arrive dans la des
fondations en béton et en se posent
dessus là avant que possible 3h05
on s'orientait un petit peu mal on a
beaucoup beaucoup de mobilier qui fait
écho aux propos du poids il a fallu très
vite ajuster le tir au mieux calculer ça
en phase de conception et pouliot et son
officiel et on s'est rendu compte qu'en
fait on on allait peut-être dépassé si
on continue comme ça donc on a marre et
adapté et on envisageait plutôt un
bardage extérieur
qui est ultra léger très économique
également et donc on a préféré valoriser
lusage à l'esthétique qui seront
d'accord ça est en tout cas valoriser
les usages c'est à dire que référé voilà
quelque chose qui correspond vraiment
aux clients à l'ensemble des besoins
qu'ils avaient dans leur petite amie
plutôt qu un bardage extérieur je sois
cher est effectivement très beau ou qui
plaît à tout le monde c'est pas une
chose qu'on a recherché cherchait
vraiment un habitat sur mesure la taille
ne s'est vraiment faite pour ça elle est
l'unique aller sur mesure et elle répond
à des besoins
elle répond lé correspond à ces petites
choses être il ya pas de modèle et pat
est alors on sort de tout ça et à chaque
fois c'est une
il nous aurait une vraie expérience qui
permet d'adapter conception sur mesure
donc les raisons qui les raisons qui
poussent à faire le choix de vivre
yao sont multiples et plus pour ans et
la restriction du budget le nombre des
espaces il ya quand même plusieurs
points qu'il faut qu'il faut enfin tout
cas qui nous intéresse c'est c'est
d'abord c'est d'abord de la volonté de
sortir des codes actuels et surtout la
volonté d'investir son temps et son
argent dans dans autre chose qu'un
crédit immobilier au présent dans du
ménage de l'entretien des abords d'une
maison
effectivement l'époque actuelle ne
pousse à avoir une grande maison et pour
ses grandes maisons il faut la remplir
en achetant beaucoup de choses tout ça
en fait ça nous prend énormément
d'argent et de temps et est la taille
minuscule est forcément est beaucoup
moins gourmande en ressources en énergie
et donc tout le temps vous gagnez tout
l'argent vous gagnez entre guillemets
aviron tanios vous pouvez mettre
comporte huit baies comme assistant avec
vos amis hier ce que vous aimez vous
voulez voyager
deuxième raison c'est pour
en mode de vie éco responsable et
écologique effectivement la tania on se
comprend très vite ça d'habitat qui est
relativement écologique puisque c'est
une mini maison en bois le bois
excellent bilan carbone il ya des
isolants qui sont bio sourcés donc on
est sur invitation et autres
l'écologique 0 litres d'eau chez ikea
l'erc lui par enel chauffeur de 33
mouvement avec un un poil de poche est
en fin de vie elle peut être entièrement
aux sites et aux presses tôt un
excellent rapport écologique
le troisième point qui est important
pour nous c'est le choix dans le devis
qui est qui est alternatif qui est sur
mesure qui est centrée sur l'essentiel
effectivement à
vu sa taille inutile de vouloir posséder
d'accumuler à tout prix on oublie la
vaisselle de ma vie pour lui faire
plaisir
on oublie l'intégrale en dvd de vos
séries préférées dans fait triompher tri
dans ses affaires et on emporte juste
l'essentiel des sauvages et quelque
chose comme dans l'être quelque chose
donc voilà déjà après vicky complètement
alternatif et on retrouve on retrouve
vraiment le l'essentiel la solide
ensuite un quatrième et dernier point
c'est le fait de pouvoir déménager
on voudrait pas de 3g sans faire ses
cartons
effectivement la tania hausse et sur une
remorque tractée par un véhicule et vous
suffit d'avoir un permis de conduire
leur mort et vous pouvez du coup voyager
avec votre maison d'ailleurs voilà les
raisons qui pour nous nous intéresse aux
tenants ensuite dans une thani
on peut imaginer vivre seul sans
problème à 2 plus compliqué ça va mettre
votre couple est brevetable et bien
droit
jusque là le couple d'amis qui a fait la
première tania s'ils ont un enfant mon
temps donc c'est possible
rassurez vous vous sentez par les droits
de tania hausse puisque en fait elle est
équipée de pas mal de fenêtres du musée
extérieur qui permettent de permettre au
regard de s'échapper et de profiter du
paysage environnant niners poussent les
habitants à vivre sur l'extérieur
généralement notre droit qui sont quand
même relativement agréable et donc on
profite plus de l'espace installé je
reviens sur cette image mais en fait
du coup qu'on nous la tania hausse ça ça
s'arrête pas seulement un petit habitat
qui est ignorant et
et c'est cool dit vivre parce que c'est
écologique etc ok pour tout ça c'est
vrai mais c'est aussi c'est aussi autre
chose
la taille mais aussi en tout cas la mode
vintage se développent du lien social
puisque il faut au fond du dialogue pour
expliquer ce creux de vie à ses voisins
qui vous pour arriver à une hausse est
chez eux
il faut du dialogue pour pour présenter
ce projet de nouveau mode de vie au
service urbanisme qui doivent aussi
accepter a toujours le cas donc voilà
faire preuve de patience de pédagogie et
tout ça en fait favori d'une lumière
sociale représente la taoussa aussi pour
nous beaucoup de potentiel là je vous ai
présenté plus tôt la maison individuelle
mais on peut on peut aussi imaginer
qu'on puisse répondre à des
problématiques qui sont acquis son
actuel notamment notamment face à
l'étalement urbain qui est pour le batik
en ce moment où la taille du groupe
portée de l'intensité maîtrisé on peut
imaginer aussi ça répondent à des enjeux
d'habitat d'urgence ou d'habitat
éphémère ça rejoint france est connue
auparavant mais ça pourrait aussi une
solution complémentaire pour créer des
solutions essais menés à tignes tout en
prenant réellement le besoin qu'on me
déplacer en plus donc ça ça nous paraît
aussi essentiel et on peut dépasser
concept de la guitare peut très bien
imaginer que ça puisse répondre à des
besoins professionnels
imaginez vous avec un bureau qui n'a pas
d'attaché pour pouvoir travailler dans
un endroit différent ça peut être assez
intéressant
donc pour nous
[Musique]
en fait c'est comme un rêve d'enfant
devenu réalité comme une cabane en fait
de 16 m² environ
équipé de tout le confort moderne et
qu'on peut déplacer au gré des envies
en fait ce rêve c c'est devenu une
réalité puisque c'est
rose qui le paierait et nous on est mais
assez fier de pouvoir développer ce
nouveau à un mode de vie là avec mes
deux collègues
merci
[Applaudissements]